Biden declines meeting with Dem Mayors
demanding action on Border crisis yeah
yeah yeah we get it Biden doesn't care
let me give you the actual story here's
a video Texas installed a border fence
to keep illegal migrants out the federal
government came in and lifted it to
allow hundreds of illegal immigrants to
pour in they say it's not a crisis it's
an invasion can I get this uh video
there you go I I am I am this is like
this is crazy when did this happen let
turn that down so th this is just first
let me just let me just say what the
this is clearly a video that appears to
be Eagle Pass I'm not entirely sure we
we we are not we don't have the exact
location or whatever confirmed but you
clearly have CBP trucks there and a
backloader lifting up the razor wire
allowing this is hundreds of people what
in the actual head hell how is it is
mindblowing that the federal government
is lifting up breaking the law lifting
like not only do they not enforce the
law but they're breaking the law as
aiding and abetting people that are
breaking the law this is mindblown I
just want to stress this once again and
you know we'll definitely tie in Aid to
Israel with it all too the federal
government hates you they are taking
your money and your savings they are
spending it on money to blow up kids and
they spending it to facilitate criminal
activities in this country when okay I
just what would you call it if members
of your own of of individuals in your
own government are giving resources and
material Aid to people who are not
citizens in order for those people to
break the laws of your country yeah I
think that's treason it might be treason
but they're not we're not at war with
these people so maybe not but once again
to bundle bundle all of it up together
just to make it we'll make it anti-war
too yeah we we they're not taking care
of us if you're on the left ask yourself
why you don't have Healthcare okay if
you're on the right ask why it is your
savings is your your buying power
continually goes down it doesn't matter
who you are or what you want we can all
agree the first step is these people
need to be stopped we need to get get
them out of government we need to we
need we need law enforcement to stop
people who are committing crimes this is
like okay treason and I don't have the
whole definition of the word treason but
it's the crime of attacking a state
authority to which one owes Allegiance
the federal government owes its
allegiance to the state of Texas it owes
its allegiance to every state in the
Union and if it's violating Texas law to
inite criminals uh that's treasonous in
my opinion just a sentence of it I don't
know do we know anything more about this
like when this happened or who ex this
has been Ono this has been ongoing there
was actually the bigger story was that
CBP was snipping the Razer Wire yeah
remember that and this is a component of
that okay so I'm assuming this video is
probably recent considering this whole
Eagle Pass thing has has been going on
in the past several weeks but and then
is there ever any explanation like cuz I
remember seeing the Snipping have they
ever said anything about that yeah they
they claim that they're legally
obligated to allow people into the
country to apply for Asylum or something
like that wow but here's the issue if
they're here mhm allowing them the the
argument is once they cross the middle
of the river now that they're in America
they can't be deported and I'm just like
yeah I don't buy it because I think it
was Texas that put the buoy uh barrier
in the water and they came and said you
got to get that out now it's like well
hold on when you put it in the water you
say nope it has to go when you put it on
land you say oh well they're already
here we is this confirmed that this is
actually this is exactly what we think
it is because I've seen a lot of fake
videos these days fair point
but I mean this is this is a CBB truck
okay so this is uh Ain B Cabello citizen
journalist document the document the
migrant journey and he says Eagle Pass
Texas Texas State versus Federal battle
continues this time with forklifts this
is November 2nd La last week the federal
government used a forklift to raise wire
and let 300 migrants in so I don't
believe it's a forklift I believe it's I
believe it's a backloader I could be
wrong I remember I saw a video recently
of people like putting cardboard and
stuff under the barb wire crawling and
then they actually made them turn around
and go back wow but that again that was
just kind of a random video on Twitter
there's another there's another video
where border patrol opens the gate at
the Ballard fencing and lets people in
and they're just like
I'm just like what this is why they got
so mad when Trump said build a wall they
before before Trump said we're going to
go ham on the border these people were
just coming across and what was
happening is really interesting they
weren't reporting apprehensions because
there weren't any so when they say there
were only 50,000 apprehensions
immigration was low no it was probably
550,000 illegal Crossings and only
50,000 actually apprehended When Donald
Trump started apprehending apprehension
Skyrocket and they said see it's getting
worse under Trump now we can see what's
going on you're right they're not being
apprehended they're being welcomed in
and we do know the Biden Administration
was trafficking children I want to
stress this statement of fact the Biden
Administration statement of absolute
fact trafficked migrant children have a
nice day they're helping blow up
children in Gaza right now
too that's fair and they're also blowing
up children in many other countries yeah
right
let's let's we I'm not biased we can't
be biased about one yeah I mean uh Yemen
secret war in Yemen I mean that's been
ongoing for a really long time but I
guess uh who was just saying that the
the crisis has only just ended probably
because the US is Shifting all of its
resources to in Yemen yeah well there's
been a ceasefire between the houthis who
control most of North Yemen and the
Saudis who the US was backing in that
war which is a very brutal War there's
been a ceasefire that held since April
2022 relatively well there hasn't been
any air strikes there's been fighting at
the board
but now you have the houthis fire
missiles at Israel and things could get
you know it puts the Saudis in a Dave
spot I don't care okay we should not be
funding it right we should not be
involved in this we should be but we are
I know that's the thing that's why we do
need to care because to the houth cuz
you might not care not many people are
aware but if you read hthy media every
attack every bombing every shelling is
not just the Saudis doing it they call
it us Saudi aggression so but I'll
clarify I'm kind of being a dick I of
course care about War I don't want I
don't want it to happen but I think the
US makes it worse you're right and then
they're spending my money to make it
worse and we had this we had a excellent
amazing conversation this morning with
uh Steven Marsh on the culture war and
uh we were basically just like the the
what what Stephen said something like
the us if you're going to go up against
the US military you're in trouble and
I'm like why they lose every war but
they win the engagements that's a
horrifying thing to say the US can
actually blow you up successfully but
they can't maintain control it just
falls apart they don't have like War
goals I haven't has seen like a
legitimate War goal from the United
States government they just want to keep
the wars going since like World War II I
mean there hasn't been a war legal War
in the United States since World War II
had none of them declared Vietnam I
don't know what the purpose of that war
was they never really if that Conflict
Vietnam was it to get oil they never
really said stop communism containment
it was to con it was to contain
Communism because they were they were
considered it the Domino Theory which
was as countries fell to Communism more
countries would fall to commun that's
like a never ending so that's not really
a war ended kind of it was it was it was
a proxy war with with the Soviets and I
think they were trying to get Malaysian
oil and they just haven't never want to
tell they won't say that out loud a lot
of Malian they Tri to World War I World
War II and the Cold War were all
basically the same thing obviously the
right so the so Vietnam is a component
of the US was at war with the Soviets
but we were all scared if we engage in
direct conflict nuclear weapons will fly
so we did these we're we're in with war
in Vietnam and it it was really Soviet
and communist Chinese interests well you
see what they're doing in Ukraine they
they use the same justification the
claim is that if Putin isn't stopped in
Ukraine he's going to roll into Eastern
Europe but that's just complete nonsense
yeah nonsense doesn't even cut you got
you got to do the narrator meme he would
not yeah he would not but you know John
M shimer he's the international
relations Professor the realist guy uh
his lectures you know really popular on
YouTube he talks he was always warning
for years in years that the US in the
West Was going to provoke a war in
Ukraine he always says that before 2014
the coup Kiev and the Civil War in the
dbass and Russia annexing Crimea he said
before that they never said Putin was
you know trying to go into Europe that
was never a talking point then all of a
sudden he became this guy who runed to
reinstate the Russian Empire and you
know roll into Poland but it's just a
nonsense talking point Putin I think
three or four weeks ago maybe a month
and a half ago was like the collective
West has lost its mind or the West has
lost its Collective mind it was just a
hilarious statement he's just looking at
it like what in the hell is doing he's
right I don't think a good guy but he's
right I'm it's so weird like oh jeez
dude we how do we strip this apart the
the the the bifurcation in American
politics is is just so insane the uh the
the there's no unification on on what
this country should be doing there are
people who are holding on to the last
vestages of the American constitutional
republic there's a lot of them but then
I think the average run-ofthe-mill
person doesn't know where and then the
left is act actively seeking to subvert
I think what we're seeing with the uh we
talked about this this morning again uh
you know Stephen mentioned that the
United States was born of rebels and
that Rebel mentality exists within our
documents our documents were written by
rebels and we maintain that even to the
Civil War it all makes sense right and
uh and and then Phil brought up exactly
what the government is doing and I said
they're trying to Stamp Out The Rebel
Spirit which is a component of why
they're like get as many nonre people to
come into the United States and that
will start to erode our ideals that's
part of the thing one of the things that
I'm concerned about with uh not just
with cbdcs like Central Bank digital
currencies but also with the idea of um
basic minimum uh basic living Universal
basic Ubi um when people are are on the
government
payroll and everyone is on the
government payroll that really is going
to make
people completely subservient now
there's still people that are like I
don't need the government I don't want
to deal with the government all I want
to do is live my life in a way that is
as independent as possible if you have a
cbdc definitely if you have some kind of
Ubi there's going to be so many people
that are just completely and totally
dependent on the government more so than
now now most people in urban areas most
people in cities are are on some level
dependent on the government even if it's
dependent on on the government to make
sure that they can get out of their
driveway if it snows or you know to make
sure that they have water and and and Su
sewage plumbing and stuff like that um
but if you have people that are getting
a
Ubi everything is going to be dependent
on the government every all of their
income all that means that you're
dependent on the government to eat but
realistically the moment a Ubi goes into
effect the economy spirals out of
control and within a month there's no
economy at all I I strong no's e yeah I
just saw that uh we what do we print a
trillion dollars in the last three
months a trillion yeah it's crazy I
think it took 250 years to get to the
first trilli and what what was it uh 80%
is just specifically for zinsky himself
personally just just going B him a big
mansion and a big boat his cat Biden's
asking for $105 billion doll to fund the
war in Ukraine the war in Gaza to give
military aid to Taiwan so they could
work on provoking another war in
Southeast Asia and there is some for
border security that to entice the
Republicans but right it's just an
insane amount of money $105 billion but
I love this Biden's like we need money
for Ukraine and and Israel and Taiwan
and the border and the border and the
Republicans are like border border can I
go to my om bus I'm looking at the US
national debt clock oh we going say
about I was say taiwan's the crazy thing
because I don't know how the US
maintains a conflict with a with an
island 90 Mi off the coast of mainland
China yeah I don't know but I what you
do man I've heard rumors that there are
uh that the United States has uh Special
Forces there yeah we have a few they
recently sent a few hundred troops to
Taiwan it's really the highest troop
level since the US and China normalized
relations because part of that deal was
for the US to pull its troops out and
its Mutual defense treaty with Taiwan
and eventually stop selling them weapons
but the way they made that commitment
was so vague that they'll tell you they
can interpret it in 12 different ways
but uh big part of it was pulling the
troops out and recently the US sent
about one to 200 troops which doesn't
sound like a lot but if you're China you
know it's very provocative to China and
you mentioned sustaining a war yeah real
quick make a point imagine if China
stationed 100 troops in Cuba yeah China
has has actual police forces inside the
United States that's a good point I mean
like actual like they're not policing
regular Americans but they're policing
Chinese Americans what's the story with
that because I've
heard like I think them calling it
police stations is a pretty uh like
dramatic way to describe it's it's it's
it's Chinese law enforcement operating
out the United States with offices to go
to Chinese citizens living in the United
States and arrest them for crimes
against China from what I understand
that's not what it is I again this is
something I don't really know about but
FBI said thought it was okay I'm not a
big fan of the FBI says a lot of things
right yeah from what I understand they
have these kind of like uh offices where
they that are you know on paper you know
they they say that they're there to help
Chinese uh Americans like with certain
documents and stuff and then they might
be going after dissidence through those
offices yeah which a lot of countries do
I mean India might have killed a seek in
Canada you know if that was China that
killed a weager in Canada we would be
talking about that every day yeah but
India kind of you know the US is looking
at India as this new partner in
containing China this is from new yor
New York Post says that they've opened
four police stations Chinese in North
America three of them are in Toronto
one's in New York City but you I I know
they do what does that mean station to
to Target Chinese Americans for for
infraction who knows so maybe one thing
on paper and but I want to stress this I
think it's fair to say that there's
definitely a a very warped perspective
on what China is like from for Americans
yeah and I think uh we we often get
people saying like get on you know lawi
or serpenta to come on and talk about
China you go to a Chinese City and
you're going to go to pizza and you're
going to have a slice of pizza like
these things exist there there's
competing interest and power at play and
there's no Saints there's no Saints and
there's no saviors I get the vi I've
been to Shanghai was uh did you have the
hot did you stuff get the stuffed crust
with the hot dog in it no see that's
what I'm talking about you go to China
and this is what concerns me you go to
piz I think it's pizza and they will
stuff make a make they will stuff your
cross with anything including hot dog I
get the vibe that they're way more
they're way more Allied and aligned with
the United States than like the the
Iranians like the Chinese are severely
oligarchic businessmen they don't want
conflict or War destruction they want to
improve improve improve and they're
willing they want to buy us out if
anything the you are correct the Chinese
try to cut deals with American
politicians to gain power they want to
buy land they want to use soft power to
expand whereas Iran very different and
I'm using Iran as an example but the
people that have been heavily
radicalized in the Middle East from all
these bombings and things well the
people that have been heavily
radicalized in the Middle East are
radicalized for multiple different
reasons the Chinese like like Tim said
it's all soft power but they still want
to be able to influence and they want to
be you know they're using soft power but
it is to have the United States have
policies that benefit China whether they
be indirectly or directly benefiting
China you know but um but China I mean
CH the really scary thing about Taiwan
so you mentioned sustaining a war right
off China's Coast if you look at the
think tanks have been putting out these
war games and about what a battle would
be like the first battle over Taiwan
like the first few weeks and they never
consider nuclear escalation so this is
the really scary part about China is
that our Pentagon our military leaders
you hear them say they're openly
planning for a direct war with China
they're saying trying to deter War but
if it happens they're going to take him
head on they have nukes but anyway with
the war games they again they don't take
into account nuclear escalation but
besides that in the first few weeks a
naval battle over Taiwan thousands and
thousands of American Sailors will be
killed Scott Horton recently just
interviewed Lyall gold Goldstein he
worked at the naval war college for 20
years he speaks Chinese he's an expert
on this he was saying he thinks tens of
thousands of American American Sailors
would be killed in the first few weeks
well there there was a we talked about
this I think think the other day that
that China does a war game and in every
single scenario a US carrier gets sunk
immediat on war games it's really the
same result we got we got to we got to
do like a like a war game like a D and D
style war game that'd be fun that' be
really cool oh we talked about doing
this we should do two we should do World
War III and and Civil War and do like a
2hour long D and D session style thing
yeah there was a does sound fun these
boats and we should bring uh you and
Scott and you guys can be like no guys
get along man no you know you're going
to rooll plays Neons okay yeah that
sounds fun I think you know them well
enough and you're going to be like War
I'm like Scott's going to be like I'm
John Bolton there's like a World War II
RPG like 2020 or something 2030 I don't
know they had it I used to play it in
the 90s or we had the book but the see
boats boats are like so vulnerable to
Hypersonic missiles now especially close
boats that are close to the Chinese land
like they're sitting targets and that's
what China's been preparing for is a war
right there you someone just sent me a a
um an email or tweeted tweeted at me
there's an injunction for uh the state
of Texas got an injunction on the
federal government for what they were
doing uh it says the date on it is one
second uh filed 1027 23 so that this
this they said was from last week it's
possible that this video is from before
the yeah yeah yeah this is probably what
caused the injunction caus them to get
the to to seek the injunction so to the
state of Texas the state of Texas got an
injunction on the federal government to
get them to
stop basically knocking down the borders
so that way IL immigrants can come into
the country maybe not treason but
they're definitely attacking State
Authority by going into Texas they're
aing and abetting people who are who are
not citizens who are committing crimes
against our nation yeah cuz technically
the feds are supposed to take care of
the border right like not the state of
Texas because it's an international
border so the federal government has
jurisdiction and they're totally
advocating their their author or not
only what do you say abdicating it but
also violating it well yeah that's what
they're not doing their job as and
they're making it worse too it's not
that they're just not there it's that
they're in there cutting the Barb wires
and letting people in thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at Tim cast.com for
uncensored membersonly shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next
time